you ready yeah see the spider-man far
from home extended complete with new
scenes and action sequences Oh
can I come
spider-man and far from home extended
kind only in theaters the spider-man far
from home extended cut with new footage
is now in theaters how's it going
everyone its Warren and if you enjoyed
Spiderman far from home you are in luck
it is back in theaters with more footage
now as you just saw Marvel has released
an ad that shows a little bit of new
footage for spider-man far from home but
what they did show is really quite
interesting it seems like we have a Tony
Stark device that was made for
spider-man that he got to use that
wasn't in the film and then of course it
seems like they took the deleted scene
with the Manfredi mob where spider-man
is wearing the iron spider suit in the
beginning of the movie and they put that
in the extended cut as well and for
those of you who are wondering this is
not going to be like the new footage in
avengers endgame which really wasn't any
new footage in the movie this new
footage is actually going to be in the
movie not put in a post-credits scene so
let's go ahead and talk about the new
spider-man far from home extended cut
and these new short clips that we saw
quick reminder about my xbox one and ps4
giveaway be sure to subscribe to my
channel like the video and comment with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter I'm picking a winner at
five hundred thousand subscribers
getting very close so with the
spider-man fired from home extended cut
we are supposed to get approximately
four minutes of new action footage and
we can see part of a new scene in this
footage that Marvel has released for the
promotion of the new extended cut for
spider-man far from home and what we see
here is a robotic spider now this is
most likely some kind of stark tech it
probably operates in some kind of way
that a drone would operate in the scene
where it's on Peters backpack it looks
like Peter is holding something and this
is most likely a remote for it now it's
hard to really tell anything about this
scene but it does seem like he's
possibly using the spider to spy on
somebody it seems like he could be at
school so maybe he's trying to spy on
Brad and MJ but Marvel is advertising
new action footage and in this new
advertisement they show a scene that we
never saw in the movie and that is Peter
Parker in some kind of a restaurant
taking on the Manfredi mob wearing the
iron spider suit so for those of you who
were wondering what happened to this
scene why it didn't make it
movie you can now go watch it in the
extended cut and also if you wanted to
see Peter Parker in his iron spider suit
for one last time you now can spider-man
far from home was great the first time
around and I'm excited to go see the new
extended cut with a little bit of new
footage so comment down below with what
you think this new robotic spider is and
let me know if you're going to see the
extended cut of spider-man far from home
let me know in the comments down below
and again don't forget to comment with
your favorite superhero or villain like
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be
sure to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you so
much for watching
woof woof